Hello, listener. We're in the middle of a songwriting operation here with Sean P. Hayes. Okay, it goes like this. We are three guys talking today. We one of us just might be gay. There's just two that might be straight. Can I just, sorry just might be gay. Hey, hey. There's just two that might be straight. Can I just, sorry, might be gay? Yeah, because nobody knows which one of the three of us is.
You think that nobody knows which one of the three of us. No, one of us is definitely gay. Can you work that? Everybody knows. Five, six, seven, eight. What are you talking about? We are three guys talking today. One of us is definitely gay.
Hey, hey. Welcome to Smartless. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less.
So, Sean, you're still in New York City. Yeah, I am. Would you ever consider living there full time? So Sean, you're still in New York City. Yeah, I am. Would you ever consider living there full time? It's funny you say that. No, because Scottie and I had a long conversation about it. We have the short version?
Yes. I mean, this is what, this is the rhythm of the question answer dynamic. The walk us through what's is you're sitting in a chair, Scotty brings a couple pop tarts, he puts them in front of you, he says, Sean, I want to talk to you about something. Yes, all right. No, for the first time ever, I've been kind of getting used
to it, like I understand, because I associate the city with work and work only, and because I've had some extra downtime, I was like, oh, I finally get it. I never walked through Central Park. I walk through Central Park all the time now. I was like, God, this place is huge and it's beautiful. By the way, you know what I do when I walk? I started walking in Central Park at dusk.
And what I do is I flex my lats and hold my head up really high because I'm scared somebody's, to make myself appear bigger than I am. So I don't. And you think the lats will do it. Yeah, because I get scared. You think that your lats are scared. Yeah.
It's like a cobra, you know, you flare out the back. That's right, that's exactly right. You make yourself seem bigger. Hey, I'm going to, we got one right here, we got a live one right here. Oh fuck, are you crazy? Look at the lats on this guy. Look at the fuck, like a bat wings.
I'm staying away. Abort, abort. The great Will Speck knows how to flare out the old bat wings. I do though, I get scared. Sean, quick question. The blanket that's draped over the chair behind you, who did it?
I did it. You did that? You fold it and then you drape it. And you did the drape. It's nice, yeah. Do you punch the pillows? You're not a pillow karate chopper, yeah, thanks. Sorry JB, yeah, you're not a karate chopper. Scotty probably a little bit more than me, yeah. I don't care about that as much.
But a little bit more, so you're saying you're both going around chopping pillows. Yeah, that's not a euphemism. Well, listen, but you know, Sean and Scotty have nice things. Look at behind him there. We got sconces, we've got stuff on the bookshelves, other than books. JB, have you been to their apartment in New York?
No, never invited. That's terrific. Oh, that's great. I invited you, I asked you, you had to work, but I said you and Franny come over when Franny was in. Just the once. Have you been in New York recently at all, JB? Yeah. Yeah, you haven't. Since January. Yeah, since been in New York recently at all, JB? Yeah.
Yeah, you haven't. Since January. Yeah, since January, okay. Oh my God, please come over anytime. No, no, no, no, why start now? Will, you've been there a couple times? I have, yeah. After you guys got back from Istanbul,
did you go through there? I keep a few things there, just because I'm there so much. Do you really? No, I don't, you fucking dummy. Hey, wait, Sean, what'd you just pull up in frame there? Is that, oh that's what we're talking about with Scotch, is it apple juice?
It's apple juice. It's so good, right, with a lot of ice. You're drinking apple juice with ice? Yes. You have a real, I'll bet you a half a dozen max of our listeners know someone that drinks a glass of milk or three every day and apple juice on ice.
That's right. I mean, you are absolutely, you are Mr. Americana. Yeah, you gotta. Not just that, it's like 1973 in your house. I have pop tarts too. No, we know, man. And slippers and. And then you have, you guys have a.
I got JB, I got JB a pair of these. Yes, you did. Wait, we've got a guest waiting. You know what, Sean, we do have a guest. I do want to say this, Sean, you were the first person and now I do it. This is years ago when he was wearing slippers and I go, hey man, are you wearing slippers at dinner?
No way. And he wore them out and I kind of went like, I guess it's okay to wear slippers out. I've never done it. Because I'm just going to my house to go sit down and eat and then go back to my house. Right. You know what I mean?
Well, sweatpants is the universal sign for when you've hit fuck it, right? When you're wearing sweatpants outside. But if you wear slippers. Well, JB, we live in an era now, though, where everybody, you know, they've called it athleisure to try to dress it up. So, and it's a huge, obviously,
it's a huge industry athleisure. It's a huge quarter of the year. Stop saying that. Well, I've never heard it before. Yeah, so it's a huge industry, athleisure, it's a huge quarter of the- Stop saying that. Well, I've never heard it before. Yeah, so when you see people out during the day and you're at the fucking Beverly Center and they're wearing stretchy pants and a stretch up
and you're like, are we in a workout class together? And they're like, no, I just walk around the world like this. Right, but it's so comfortable. I know, I know it's comfortable, man, but so are my fucking pajamas, But like, what am I doing? Yeah, we're naked. You're not allowed to walk around naked.
Yeah, we're not at your house, man. Yeah. We're not all. I could never do it, but I get like, I don't like jeans or pants that are super tight, you know, that they're constricting. God, I could go anywhere. Go ahead.
I get wanting to wear athletes. This is a humble brag. He's saying he needs a lot more room in there. I just think that the whole, I think that there's an entire segment of our population that it's hit, fuck it. It's not even fucking that they think that it's appropriate to like, by the way,
I wear shorts out sometimes and a t-shirt, but I'm not like, I don't say it. No. No. No. Jason, how much longer do you have to go on the show? Two weeks. Oh, that's it?
Can you believe it? And then it's all coming on now. Is it beard and hair at the same time? Yeah, over the course of two or three days, yeah, cause we gotta do the state of the flashback. I can't wait to see you clean shaven and clean. I know, I can't. I'm gonna look so weird.
Will you miss this look? I'll look old probably, right? Do you think I'll look older? Durr, yeah. Sorry, I meant to say durr. Right, because... Um... Because one...
Our guest liked it. Yeah, she seems like she's in a good mood. She's in a very good mood. You know what, let's get to her. She's so much fun, because I want to hear what she has to say about your face and your beard coming off and stuff. And I'm really excited because I love having
a good friend on here, especially like an old friend, somebody who likes to laugh and have a good time. Mix it up. Do we all know her? Do we all know her? Somebody, I don't know how well you two guys know her. She and I have been friends for a number of years and I'll tell you why, because you'll guess once I say why.
But she is, and I don't like it. you know, there's this thing now where people say in the world all the time Oh my god, you're my favorite human. I That expression drives me. Yeah, that's almost it's almost up there with wearing fucking stretch pants There are dogs that outrank you but as far as humans go they people use that you're my favorite human Just say person you one of my favorite people. You don't need to say human. But anyway, she is one of my favorite humans. Human.
And so I'm gonna use it. I'm breaking my own rule because I'm a hypocrite through and through. And she's just such a wonderful person. She's so fun to laugh with and talk to. She's super smart, super cool. But then when you look at, so I want to say that. I love her as a person, and I also love and respect her
as an artist, as a performer. She's so amazing. She's been nominated for UMTEME Awards, and she's won Golden Globes and Critics' Choice Awards for lots of different stuff. You might remember her from, you know, from the Mickey Mouse Club. You might know her from Honey, I Blew Up the Kid.
She was nominated for a Young Artist Award for that. She's gonna kill me. You might remember her from a lot of different things. You might remember from her two episodes of Roar that she did with Heath Ledger back in the day, but you're definitely gonna remember her from a lot of different things. You might remember from her two episodes of Roar that she did with Heath Ledger back in the day. But you're definitely gonna remember her. Definitely. Hand on buzzer, hand on buzzer.
Yeah, you're definitely gonna remember her from her show, which is going to a second season soon, The Diplomat. You also know her from The Americans. You know her from Felicity. You guys, it's my friend, Kari Russell. It's Margot Martindale. Oh, hey Russell. Oh my God, Sean, did you say Markdale?
Margot Martindale. Margot Martindale. Who is equally as great. There she is! Oh my God. Hello Kerry. Kerry! Oh my God, it's so great to see you. Margot Martindale!
Kerry Russell! Margot Martindale would be my favorite guest. Margot Martindale would be my favorite guest. Margot was busy, so we got Carrie. Understood, understood. I get it. But, and I didn't even want to mention, and I couldn't mention Matthew, because if I say, once I say Matthew,
then the jig is up. So I had to like work backwards, and I know you're gonna kill me. You're not gonna kill me for the Mickey Mouse Club. I love that. You were on the Mickey Mouse Club? Were you on when... With like Britney Spears and all that?
Was Ryan Gosling on that as well? No way. With them, you were on... All of you were on the same thing? Oh yeah. That's crazy. Ask me anything. This is... I mean, that is gold. That is pure gold.
Wait, Carrie. Hi. First of all, hi Carrie. Hi. So nice to see you. It is so nice to see you. So nice to see all of you. And you, are you home? I just got home. I've been filming in London and I just got home
just a few days ago. So I'm home getting kids ready for school. My teenagers helped me set all this stuff up. Oh, they did. Yeah, yeah. Are you good at adjusting time, different time zones? Or are you like still on jet lag? I'm jet lagged, but I really love the early mornings.
So even though I'm still getting up at four, it's like such a quiet time in my house. So I love just like pitter-pattering. Let me tell you something about Carrie. And Jason, you're going to appreciate this. And Sean, it goes to your question, which is, she's so disciplined. It's crazy. She can just like kind of do anything.
She's like, what's the task? Okay, so I'll do this. So's crazy. She can just like kind of do anything. She's like, what's the task? Okay, so I'll do this. So I'll get up early and I'll do the thing. Like she just does stuff. Are you a Capricorn, Carrie? I'm not. What are you?
I'm an Aries. I don't know. We don't know anything. That's the end of me. All I know is about my own sign. Really? And you're, well. Out of the not shocking department.
My wife can come in here and break you down. My wife would ask you, you're rising and you're moon. I don't know any of that, but I'm into it, but I don't know any of that. Wait, Carrie, do you remember that one time, this is like decades ago, and you know what I'm gonna say. We were, you were with an acting coach and you came out and I was going in
and that's when we first met. This is like 25, 30 years ago, like a super long time ago. Which acting coach? I don't remember. But it was her house, it was this acting coach's house and it was like a back, it was like a guest house in the back and you were coming out and I was going in and I was like, oh my God.
Be careful, because a lot of people listen to this. It was that, well, she's like a really intense teacher that she did like Al Pacino and stuff like that, right? Oh, crazy intense. Maybe, I don't know. Like, it was behind in her house, not Venice, but like kind of adjacent Venice, right? Sean, you don't remember her name either?
I don't. Sean, do you wish some of those classes had stuck? Like, do you wish some of the... I fucking wish some of those classes had stuck. That do you wish some of the... I fucking wish some of those classes had stuck. That would have been so fun if some of that had worked. For you, I mean. Sean, I wish some of those classes would have stuck. But yeah.
No, for me, I mean. What type of stuff, like, would you go in there with a specific set of sides for an audition that's coming up and you work on it? Oh, yes. Yeah, for sure. Or I got a monologue. I need a funny monologue and a dramatic monologue. Right.
Yeah. Or something. Carrie, do you remember what you were doing it for? Were you up for auditioning? I have no idea. or I got a monologue, I need a funny monologue and a dramatic monologue. Right. Carrie, do you remember what you were doing it for? Were you auditioning? I have no idea. Maybe a movie or something that, I don't know. I mean, I did it like once or twice. Probably when I met it was- This is right after Felicity.
Oh, so it was probably like just once or twice. Because a friend of mine was going, anyway. So yeah. Now, what about, you know, Will is threatening to move to, I can't keep up, it's either, it's usually England, I think now it's Portugal, but he would like to live in England, I think, as would I, I think. Where did coming back from there leave you?
I mean, would you go back? So I've spent the past three summers filming there, which I know is a little bit of a unique existence. Like you have a nice place to live, you're working, you have a job. So there are a lot of things that are extra nice. It's not like you're... But it is, London in the summer is a delight.
I mean, it is so breathtakingly beautiful. I tend to live north and by the Heath, and I wake up early morning and I walk through the Heath. I have said Heath is such a great area to live in. It is magic. It is so magic. I agree. And I've loved it.
I've really, really loved it. And actually, I don't think, well, I don't know. I don't think I'm telling tales out of school, but my last week there, we had this, so I'm on this show called The Diplomat, and it's about the ambassador in London, who's the, I'm friends with the real one, Ambassador Jane Hartley, who's just amazing
and smart and cool. And the last week, she said, we were like, let's go to dinner before I leave. And so we went to the River Cafe and that great actor, fuck, what's his name? On the Bear, who plays the cousin, Eben. Eben joined us and we just had this, like, it was just such a fun, raucous dinner. And Rufus Sewell, who's on my show too. And it's just full of, everyone who was, everyone was at this restaurant that night. It was like one of those magic, wild moments.
And so I love London. Could you see yourself living there full time, like with your whole family? Well, I don't know because I wonder if it's, you know, I love coming back here too. I get, you know, fall in New York is so good. Are you in New York now? But if you, she's in New York, you live in Brooklyn. She lives in Brooklyn.
Oh, not same. Sean, you live at Zabards. Where are you, Sean? Where are you living in the city right now? He lives like in Zabards. If you take a left at the Plain Bagels, he's... You're uptown. He lives like in Zabards. If you take a left at the Plain Bagels, but if you lived in London, I don't know if you could because first of all, Matthew as a Welshman, I mean, he'd get
in too many fights. Oh my God. Right. Yeah. But no, but he loves London. He's at the pub. I know Matthew, he's at the pub. And then all of a sudden before it's all over, he's in a fight with a bunch of Englishmen, right? Yeah. There's definitely a rivalry, but he loves London too, but I don't know. What about your teenagers, have they done some time there? They have.
Yeah, what'd they think? They like it, but they've kind of, like you guys, they travel wherever we work. So in the summer they can be with you, and would they or would they be like, because I've got a 12 year old and a 17 year old. And they just. Oh, I have exactly the same.
Plus an eight year old. Yeah, lucky you. Wow. But they're like, they've got their lives. And they've got their friends and they've got their places they'd like to go. It's like, well great, I'll see you when you get back, mom. Dad. Oh, definitely.
Right, it's hard to get them away, nor do you really want to disrupt them. Jason, your kid's name's real quick. Oh. Sorry. Great, both the girls. This is a fun game. Both the girls. Fun game, this is a fun game.
But wait, wait, by the way, Jason and Sean, have you guys, have you guys spent any time up in, like near Hampstead Heath, like up in that area? No, I love London, but not. It would blow your mind. It would shift everything you think about living in London. What's it called?
Hampstead, because it's like, it's like a massive, I want to say park, it's kind of doing it a disservice by calling it a park, but in effect it is that. It's super green. And it's got a bunch of little lakes in it, stuff where you can swim. It's wild.
It's wild, it's like a wild park. It's incredible. Carrie, could you live there or not? You're happy. I really love it, I really love it. But I have to say, you know, we shot there, when the strike happened, we had to make up for things, so we shot there over the winter,
and it's different in the winter, you know? Because New York in the winter, even if it's snowing or it's freezing, it can be sunny and it's bracing and you can still ride your bike. Yeah, London's just gray all winter. But it's raining every day. And rain all day is different than. And cold, right? Cold.
That kind of cold that gets into your bone. Even as a Canadian, I'm like, fuck, I'm freezing. Yeah, so I do love it. And it's so lush and it's so green. And the people, there's a real, I don't know, it does have a different culture than we have, but it was just a delight. Where did you start?
Where did you grow up? I moved around a lot. So I was born in California. The law kept catching you. Then I grew up, I spent 13 years in Arizona, and then Colorado, and then my parents moved to Texas. So I moved around a lot. Where was the first place you said?
Arizona. California. California, then Arizona, then Colorado. Sorry, are you getting an email coming in or you just got your what's going on? She said it like a second ago. Wait, so Carrie, so you grew up and so, and I knew that about, I always think of you, I always associate you with Colorado,
because I think you went to high school. That was my high school. High school, yeah. And probably that I dated a hockey player for half a second from Colorado. That's probably what you remember. That's what I remember too. You know I remember all the hockey stuff.
And we will be right back. And now back to the show. How did it happen that you became part of the Mickey Mouse Club? Yeah. So I was a dancer, like with all my little dance friends in Colorado, you know, like pre-teen, teenage years,
and that was my sport and that's all I did, and a bunch of my friends went to like a giant casting call and we stood outside of the Denver Convention Center with thousands of little kids and their moms or something and we just stood in line. Some dude like said, hey, do you want to read a little script of a mermaid brushing her teeth with chocolate or something? And was he part of the audition or was this just the back of a van? Yeah, he just rolled the window down. I was willing to do it. And yeah, no, so, and that's what I did. And they called me back.
Wow, I mean, that is really, first of all, that gives a lot of hope, I think, to people who are like, oh, should I bother going for that thing with thousands of people? Well, you could end up being Carrie Russell. I mean, you can't be Carrie Russell, nobody else can be. But I mean, you've built an incredible life with really impressive credits.
You've done amazing things. Was that audition something you wanted to do or did your parents tell you about it? I wanted to, I mean, I don't think I knew what it really was. I just went with a bunch of my best friends, pals who were going and they're like, let's go do this thing. And by the way, I can't sing. I had never really been an actor.
And so they said, do a little dance, do a skit, and sing a little song. Because I think they wanted kids who weren't so, yeah, they didn't like it. Still waiting to hear, yeah. Still waiting to hear. Still waiting to hear. Her friends years later was like, she didn't even want to go.
I was the one that wanted it. I was the one. And she got it. I want to ask you something, Carol, because it has to do with how Will introduced you, which is like, you do when you just came on, you weren't Margot Martindale. which is like, you do when you just came on, you weren't Margot Martindale. When you came on. By the way, you haven't been Margot Martindale
for a minute. By the way, I, and Will, I mean, there's no one better than Margot Martindale. There's Shawn Umi. Adore, she's the best. I love Margot Martindale with all my heart. Me too, me too. But your energy and your work ethic,
and you're like, you do have so much energy even talking to you now and with the kids and working and traveling and getting up at five in the morning and working 14 hours. Like where do you get that drive? Where do you get the energy? Youth, it's youth. Youth, oh my God.
Methamphetamine. Yeah, exactly. Because you do have to find it. You do have to find it, even though you're tired, you have to find it. Well, I think, well number one, I don't work all the time. Like, I like long breaks, and I spend a ton of time on my own.
I like to be alone a lot. I have amazing friends, I have a group of core friends that I love and we do stuff all the time. But other than that, I work, I spend, I have a ton of downtime. So, for instance, the diplomat. I'm not going off to do tons of movies in between or on a Broadway show or something.
That's my time to just be home and wander and read books. And that's what keeps me sane. But it is a good question because I know, so Carrie and I did this show with the great Mitch Hurwitz years ago called Running Wild, which was... And we had a lot of fun, that's how we got to know each other. And it was crazy, we were trying to make this thing happen and we were shooting just crazy hours out on Long Island.
And Carrie, I remember, we were legitimately, like the first couple weeks, we were shooting like 16 hours a day trying to get these fucking, you know, and get this thing, you know, and get this thing off the ground, which, and I remember Carrie like going either before work or after work to the gym and she had a little kid at home. She had like a three year old at home
and doing all the thing and had all this dialogue and doing all this stuff. And I was like, it was so impressive how hard, how dedicated she was to just... Like I said, she's just a doer in this way. JB, I can see the smile on JB's face. He's just like, yeah. Why? Because you are as well? Is that what you're saying?
Because he's a machine. It sounds like you. It's either going and really trying to accomplish a ton or just total power down, being by yourself, just like staring at the wall, doing something really inane and refilling the tank. Yeah, I just clean out closets, I listen to my little nerdy news podcasts.
Oh, he doesn't do that. No, he doesn't do that either. He's a staff of full staff. He goes, he watches TV and he locks the door and nobody's allowed to bother him. And you're probably not crumpy, but I will say. Amanda serves and he locks the door and nobody's allowed to bother him and you're probably not crumpy But but I will Amanda Amanda serves his food under the yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Nobody can talk to him. But me things Yeah, yeah, and he's not interested in anything. But the question is
Carrie so you do so you do that you you do the The Disney stuff and then that leads to what you how long, that's like three years I want to say? That you've been? A teenage years, yeah, teenage years. And then, and this seriously is the truth. Like whenever the girls looked like they were having sex, they were like, get that one out of here.
And the boys stayed till they were like 25. They're like, that one, she's out. Oh wow. Really? Yeah, seriously. She looks like a breeder. Get her out. Yeah, she looks like a breeder, yeah, get her out. Yeah's like, really? Yeah, seriously. She looks like a breeder. Get her out. Yeah, she looks like a breeder.
Yeah, get her out. Yeah, yeah. Exactly. Yeah, and, but it was so fun. I mean, it was so cheesy looking back, but it was so fun. And all those kids. Did it lead to anything tangible?
Like, did it, or was it just a great thing to have on your resume, and you just started to do more sort of traditional auditions. Yeah, I mean from that, because you're under this old school Disney contract, I had to do some movie, like the sequel, Honey, I Blew Up the Kid, which was a sequel to Honey, so that was part of your deal.
Ah, interesting. You know, it was like the old school system, like we hired you under this umbrella, so if you record an album, if you make a move, like you are ours, you know? We own you. Interesting. Yeah. It was a little bit like that.
That's interesting. You know, like the kids now, like all those, this new crap. American Idol kids and whatever, yeah, yeah, yeah. Or whatever all those new Disney shows are. Now Felicity was quite some time past that, but that was also on ABC. It was under the same umbrella.
That wasn't part of the same deal, was it? No, that was, it wasn't on ABC. It was under the same umbrella. That wasn't part of the same field, was it? No, that was... It wasn't on ABC. It was on something else. It was WB. Thank you. WB. It was WB.
I remember because it was their big hit show and they were a young network and then all of a sudden they had a hit. Like a legitimate hit. And that's where you met the great, our friend, the great JJ Abrams. That's right. JJ and Matt. And that was JJ's show. And Matt Reeves, yeah.
And you guys created, you guys made that network in a way. Yeah, kind of amazing. You legitimized them, because it was a great show. JJ got heralded, you got heralded. I mean, everybody kind of went like, Kerry Russell, you exploded onto the scene. I remember, you guys remember. I remember too, yeah.
Every magazine. Everybody knew who Kerry Russell was, just guys remember. I remember, yeah. Every magazine. Everybody knew who Keri Russell was. Just like that. That must have been, even though you'd been doing it for a while since you were a teenager, having that kind of thing happen must have been startling. I don't want to put words in your mouth.
And at an age where it's pretty, things are challenging already at that age, right? Kind of like figuring out who you are. How old were you? First of all, the reason the show was so good was that what JJ and Matt reason the show was so good was what JJ and Matt did, it was so sweet. It was like such a sweet little something of a show
and it was their writing that was so good. But yeah, for, luckily, I mean, I can't imagine the kids now with all of the social media. Back then, it was just occasional paparazzi weirdos. But yeah, I am sort of a nervous person anyway around people I don't know. So that only made that worse. And that was hard.
People coming up to you on the street and stuff like that, yeah? Well, I mean, people were generally pretty nice to me, but I just think if you're an anxious person It doesn't help like yeah having more people looking at you all the time. So I think That was something to sort of Navigate a little bit But then it all worked out because after that show ended I took a big break and I didn't
走在街上会有人认出你之类的，对吧？嗯，我的意思是，大家对我都挺友好的，但我只是觉得如果你是一个焦虑的人，有更多人一直盯着你看，这可帮不上忙。所以我觉得那是一段需要稍微应付一下的时期。但后来一切都迎刃而解了，因为那部剧结束后，我休息了很久，而且我没有
Act anymore. I didn't think that's what I wanted to do anymore. Really? So was that a conscious decision? You were like, hang on a second. I need to Yeah. Yeah. No way. Yeah. And where did you think you were going to go?
再演戏了。我觉得我再也不想做这一行了。真的吗？所以那是一个有意识的决定吗？你就好像，等一下。我需要——嗯。嗯。绝不。嗯。那你觉得你要去哪里？
Well, I thought I was going to go back to school or go to school because I hadn't gone to school. And because I graduated early from high school because I was in Mickey Mouse Club. You mean college? Yeah, okay, okay. Yeah, because when you're on the Mickey Mouse Club, like if you're a kid, you're tutored on set so you can finish as quickly as you can. Same with Mr. Bateman. Yeah, we know about that.
嗯，我以为我要回学校，或者去上学，因为我之前没怎么上过学。而且因为我在米老鼠俱乐部，所以高中提前毕业了。你是说大学？嗯，好吧，好吧。嗯，因为你在米老鼠俱乐部的时候，如果你还是个孩子，你在片场就会有家教辅导，这样你就能尽快完成学业。贝特曼先生也是这样。对，我们知道这事。
Sometimes they have buses to do that too. Yeah. And then, but so, God, most kids, me, part of it, like as soon as the, the kid show is done, there's a panic like, okay, what's the next show going to be like? What's my career going to be now that I'm kind of like almost an adult? Yeah. And you're dying to get another job and get back into that television series cocoon, you know, the safety of employment.
有时候他们甚至有专门的大巴来上课。嗯。然后呢，天哪，大多数孩子，包括我，其中一部分原因就是，儿童节目一结束，就会产生一种恐慌，心想：好吧，接下来会是什么节目？既然我差不多快成年了，我的职业生涯该怎么办？嗯。你渴望得到另一份工作，回到电视剧那个温馨的小茧里，也就是那种有稳定工作的安全感。
You were the opposite. You were like, not only do I not want to work, I don't even know if I want to do this occupation anymore. Yeah, I, uh, so doing that show that was back in the old days when we would do 22 episodes. Now, you know, the nature of television is tends to be like eight or 13 episodes. But we were still doing network, 22 episodes. And especially back then, we were working, because Matt Reeves was one of our first directors and set up the show, we were shooting it like film. We were shooting on film in the beginning.
而你却完全相反。你当时的想法是，我不但不想工作，甚至不知道自己还想不想做这个职业。对，我，呃，拍那部剧的时候还是老黄历，当时我们要拍22集。现在呢，你知道的，电视剧的性质往往是8集或13集。但我们当时拍的仍然是电视网的剧，足足有22集。特别是当年，因为马特·里夫斯是我们的首批导演之一，他奠定了该剧的基调，我们当时是在像拍电影一样拍电视剧。一开始我们是用胶片拍摄的。
Really? Yeah. Shooting on film? Yeah. We were working 18 hour days, five days a week. So my Friday as a 21 year old would end about five in the morning, and then I would start again at five on Monday.
真的吗？嗯。用胶片拍？嗯。我们每周工作5天，每天工作18个小时。所以作为一个21岁的年轻人，我的周五大约凌晨5点结束，然后周一早上5点又要开始。
And I loved that job and it was great, and I'm so thankful I'm still really close with a few of those people. But in many ways it was life arresting. Like I wanted to be with girlfriends, and whatever, kiss boys, or do simple, stupid things that I knew I was sort of missing. So when it ended, I had no time to spend any money
我很喜欢那份工作，它太棒了，我非常感激，而且到现在我还和其中几个人走得很近。但在很多方面，它就像是按下了人生暂停键。我想和女朋友们在一起，或者别的什么，跟男孩子接吻，或者做一些我知道自己有点错过了的简单、愚蠢的事情。所以当它结束时，我根本没时间花钱
or do any of that, so I took the money I had saved and rented this amazing apartment, one bedroom apartment in the village, which was really great still back then. And I had no furniture. I moved to New York with two giant boxes of books. I got mattresses, I put them on the floor, and I did all those things I wanted to do.
或者做那些事，于是我拿着存下来的钱，在村里租了间超棒的公寓，一室一厅的公寓，在当时那个年代真的很不错。里面什么家具也没有。我带着两个装满书的巨大纸箱搬到了纽约。我弄了些床垫，直接铺在地板上，然后开始做所有我想做的事。
I had two really great girlfriends there, and we would go out dancing and get drunk and like walk home drunk in the snow, and we would watch The Bachelor, get drunk and walk home drunk in the snow and we would watch The Bachelor Ed and eat shitty food. And it was everything I wanted it to be. And I got to just fucking be a kid. And I think that's what I wanted. Did you end up going to school?
我在那里有两个非常要好的女朋友，我们会一起出去跳舞、喝醉，然后醉醺醺地走在雪地里回家，我们还会边喝酒边看《单身汉》，醉醺醺地走在雪地里回家，还会看《单身汉》并吃垃圾食品。这一切简直就是我梦寐以求的生活。我终于他妈的能像个孩子一样生活了。我想这正是我想要的。你后来去上学了吗？
I didn't, so I thought that's what I was going to do and that's probably what I should have done. I still think about it. But I think I just sort of did it myself. I just read what I wanted to read about and took all that time off. I took, I think, a couple of years and then just slowly started inching my way back in. I took a job where I wasn't the lead. I was like a part of a family.
我没有去，我本来以为我会去的，那可能也是我当时该做的。我到现在还会想起这事。但我觉得我只是自己摸索着过来了。我只是阅读我想读的书，度过了所有那些闲暇时光。我想我休息了几年，然后才慢慢地、一点点地重新踏回这个圈子。我接了一份不是演主角的工作。我只是一个大家庭里的一员。
And actually we shot in London with Mike Binder and I was just a part of these sisters. And Joan Allen was the lead. And I was like... Was that the upside of anger? Yeah. And I was like, you know, she's cool and smart and classy. And if I can watch her, if she's managing her life okay, you know, maybe it's managing her life okay,
事实上，我们在伦敦和迈克·宾德一起拍戏，我只是那些姐妹中的一个。琼·艾伦是主角。我说……那是《愤怒的倒影》吗？嗯。我就想，你知道的，她真酷、聪明又有品味。如果我能看着她，如果她能把自己的生活过好，你知道的，也许这——把生活过好，
maybe it's possible, and she was. So then I slowly dipped back in. She stuck with it. What was the other industry that you were thinking about maybe going into? Oh God, I don't know. I think I just wanted to learn. I think I wanted to just go to school.
也许这是有可能的，她确实做到了。于是我慢慢地又涉足了这个行业。她一直坚持了下来。你当时考虑过可能会涉足的另一个行业是什么？噢天哪，我不知道。我想我只是想学习。我想我只是想去上学。
I'm interested in every, I feel like I could do lots of things. Right. I'm interested in every, I feel like I could do lots of things, you know. I'm curious, you know, but I'm generally agreeable. I'm curious about a lot. But you didn't like start like one particular career that you were thinking maybe I want to kind of go in, and then like that was kind of like,
我对什么都感兴趣，我觉得我能做很多事情。没错。我对什么都感兴趣，我觉得我能做很多事情，你知道的。我充满好奇心，你知道的，但我这个人挺随和的。我对很多事都充满好奇。但你没有开始从事某种特定的职业，比如你曾想过也许我想往那个方向发展，然后那种感觉就像是，
eh, it's not that great, and then you went back to acting? Like did you ever? No, I didn't. Yes, you didn't really start at anything, okay. No, I didn't. You didn't get into like microplastics or anything. That's a big industry apparently. It's a growth industry.
呃，其实也没那么好，然后你又回去演戏了？你曾经有过吗？不，我没有。对，你其实什么都没真正开始做，好吧。不，我没有。你没有涉足微塑料什么的吧？那显然是个大产业。那是个朝阳产业。
It's everywhere. Yeah, it's a growth industry. Wait, this is kind of to carry NJB because I'm always interested, curious about people who start performing when they're younger and are able to sustain it. When you were doing Mickey Mouse Club or J.B. you were on various shows when you were a kid.
到处都是。对，那是个朝阳产业。等等，这有点像是接着NJB的话题，因为我对那些很小就开始表演并且能够一直坚持下来的人一直很感兴趣、充满好奇。当你还在拍《米老鼠俱乐部》或者J.B.的节目时，你小时候上过各种各样的节目。
Were you cognizant of, and did people talk amongst you and your peers and your friends and your families like, hey, how can we make the jump to adult actors? Yeah, how conscious were you? How conscious were you that there's a sort of a bar there, that there's a separation between being a kid actor and then making it a life and a career? Were you aware of that?
你当时有这种意识吗？你和同龄人、朋友以及家人之间会讨论诸如“嘿，我们该如何成功转型为成年演员？”这样的话题吗？嗯，你们当时有多清醒？你有多清楚前面有一道坎，清楚童星身份与将其作为生活和职业之间存在着一条分界线？你当时意识到这一点了吗？
I wasn't, were you? Yeah, I was scared shitless of that transition. Yeah, I thought no one's gonna, you know, you're a kid actor, so why would anybody want to see you do adult acting when you're an adult? Like you gotta start over. There's not gonna be an easy transition. And it wasn't, there was, all through my 20s, it was just a barren waste field.
我没有，你呢？嗯，我对那种转型感到怕得要命。嗯，我以为没有人会，你知道的，你是个童星，为什么成年后还会有人想看你演成年人的戏呢？就像你得从头开始一样。这绝不会是一个平稳的过渡。事实也的确如此，在我的整个20岁，那简直是一片贫瘠的荒原。
And that's why you shaved your pubes till you were 22, right? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. And I did for different reasons.
这就是为什么你直到22岁才刮阴毛，对吧？嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。嗯。我这么做是有不同原因的。
Yeah. Feels nice. Guys, I can still play Young. Hey, it's me, JB. Check it out. I don't even have a pute. Check it out. Oh my God. That is really funny. Wait, so Gary, so you go, you do upside down.
嗯。感觉挺不错的。伙计们，我还能演年轻人。嘿，是我，JB。瞧瞧。我甚至都没毛。瞧瞧。噢天哪。这真的太搞笑了。等等，所以加里，你去了，你拍了《愤怒的倒影》。
Wait, Jason, wait. Have you read, because I actually, speaking of the creepy kid actors, which by the way, all kid actors, the whole thing is so creepy. But there's this amazing book that someone gave me, which I loved. By the way, all kid actors, the whole thing is so creepy. There's this amazing book that someone gave me, which I loved. Are you familiar with Sarah Pauley at all? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Absolutely.
等等，杰森，等等。你读过吗？因为实际上，说到那些让人起鸡皮疙瘩的童星——顺便说一句，所有的童星，整件事都让人觉得毛骨悚然。但有本超级棒的书，别人送给我的，我很喜欢。顺便说一句，所有童星，整件事都让人觉得毛骨悚然。有本超级棒的书，别人送给我的，我很喜欢。你对萨拉·波利熟悉吗？对，对，对，对。完全熟悉。
Now she's a director, but you know, kid actor. She wrote this book called Run Towards the Danger, which is a collection of stories and it's sort of unraveling her time and the kind of understanding what that was all like. And I thought it was great. Of being a kid actor, yeah. And a lot of other things, but I do think it affects you and speaks probably to a little bit of what Will is saying,
她现在是个导演了，但你知道的，她也是个童星。她写了一本名为《走向危险》的书，里面收录了许多故事，某种程度上梳理了她的那段经历，以及她对这一切到底是怎么一回事的理解。我觉得这本书写得真棒。作为童星的经历，嗯。还有很多其他事情，但我确实认为这会对你产生影响，这大概也正印证了威尔所说的一些话，
like what he's seeing as like work ethic, but I just think when you're a kid actor, you know, you have to show up. You're not allowed to have the flu. You're not allowed to, you fucking show up and you do it and you don't complain. You don't go. You have all this adult responsibility.
比如他所看到的这种职业道德，但我只是觉得当你是个童星时，你知道的，你必须到场。你不被允许得流感。你不被允许，你他妈的必须出现并把活儿干完，而且不准抱怨。你不能走开。你身上背负着所有这些成年人的责任。
Yeah. You're adultified, so you are. JB taught me a lot of, I will, this is truly, and I've mentioned this a couple of times, early on we were doing Arrested Development in the first season. At one point I was like, I got to the point, it didn't take long where I was like,
嗯。你被早熟化了，确实如此。JB教了我很多，我必须承认，这是真的，我曾提过好几次。早期我们在拍第一季《发展受阻》的时候。有一次我问——我甚至到了那种地步，也没花多久——
hey, what time are you rapping today? Like, you know, when I got in early in the day, I'm thinking like, what time am I out of here? And Jason turns to me and goes, we got you for the whole day, right? And it really, as funny as that was, and as funny as that was, the timing of it was perfect. His delivery was amazingly shitty,
嘿，你今天几点收工啊？就像，你知道的，当我那天去得很早时，我在想：我到底几点能从这儿离开？然后杰森转过身对我说：“我们今天一整天都有你的档期，对吧？”这真的，不管当时听起来多搞笑，不管当时听起来多搞笑，那个时机的把握简直完美。他的语气贱兮兮的，
and it was perfect and hilarious, and it broke me. But also the truth of it was, yeah man, you're here to do a thing, and you've got this, like- Yeah, you're doing the thing you wanted to do. And it really, honestly, you're here to do a thing and you've got this like yeah You're doing the thing you wanted to do and it really honestly I never forgot it and it I carried it with me for the rest of my And to this day my working career Which is like I'm there to do the thing that I got to do not to get fucking get out and I feel
完美而且极其搞笑，彻底把我逗乐了。但同时其中的真相是，是的，老兄，你来这儿就是为了干一件事，而且你已经有了这个——嗯，你在做你想做的事。说真的，老实说，你来这儿就是为了干一件事，而且你已经有了这个——嗯，你在做你想做的事。说真的，老实说，我从未忘记过这一点，它伴随了我余下的岁月。直到今天，我的职业生涯——也就是我来这儿是为了完成我必须做的事，而不是为了他妈的早点收工，我觉得
Equally pissed off when I feel like yeah I feel equally pissed off with people when they're like trying to get out and I'm like yeah, yeah you dude Yeah, yeah. It's what you signed up for. Yeah. We'll be right back. All right, back to the show. So, Carrie, about the anxiety thing,
同样感到火大，当我看到——是的，当看到别人总想着早退时，我也觉得同样火大，我就想，是的，是的，老兄，是的，是的。这就是你签约要承担的。好吧，我们马上回来。好的，欢迎回到节目中。那么，加里，关于焦虑这件事，
because I have a little bit of that too. I'm much better at it. But how do you, do you have two? bit of that too. I'm much better at it, but how do you, do you have two? Do you have two? Okay. I mean sometimes, these guys know, it comes out quite often.
因为我也有点这方面的问题。我在这方面已经好多了。但你是怎么——你也有两个？也有点这方面的问题。我在这方面已经好多了，但你是怎么——你也有两个？你也有两个？好吧。我是说有时候，这几个伙计都知道，这种情况经常会出现。
But how do you deal with it? Like do you have tools that you, your go-to tools? I wake up in the morning and I do something immediately. Like you know, I do hopefully like something outside, you know, I do, hopefully, like something outside, even if it's cold, some kind of physical activity really helps me. Even if I'm, you know, sometimes it just overtakes and you're like, fuck it, here I am.
但你是怎么应对的呢？比如说你有没有什么管用的方法，你的首选方法？我早上醒来就会立刻做点什么。比如你知道的，我希望是做点室外的事情，你知道的，我希望是做点室外的事情，哪怕天气很冷，某种体力活动确实对我很有帮助。哪怕我（的情况）——你知道的，有时这种情绪会突然涌上来，然后你就想：操，我就是这样。
You know what really helped me? One of the first times, this is absolutely true, right in the beginning of Felicity Times, before I had ever had to do any of that stuff, I had to go on a talk show. My first talk show was, Rosie O'Donnell had a talk show back then. I think it was like a daytime talk show.
你知道什么真的帮了我吗？有一次，绝对是这样，在《费莉希蒂》时期的刚开始，甚至在我不得不去做任何那种事之前，我得去上一个脱口秀节目。我的第一个脱口秀是这样的，当时露西尔·奥唐纳有个脱口秀节目。我记得那是个日间脱口秀节目。
I had never done anything like that. I kind of am a nervous person in that situation anyway. That's horror for me. And it's like, it's a lot of energy coming toward you and the stage and all the people and blah, blah, blah yeah and I got back there and the stage manager is like come over here come over here and I was like uh-oh uh-oh it's it's overtaking me here it comes and the stage manager must have told Rosie O'Donnell who was so lovely like she's nervous so she came back and was like hey are you nervous and I was like oh no no and so I went out, this is really absolutely true,
我以前从来没做过那种事。在这种情况下，我本身就是一个容易紧张的人。这对我和恶梦一样。那种感觉就像是，有大量的能量朝你涌来，还有舞台、所有的人，等等等等。嗯，我走到后台，舞台经理就说：“过来这儿，过来这儿。”我就想：噢不，噢不，情绪涌上来了，它要来了。然后舞台经理一定跟露西尔·奥唐纳说过——她人太好了——说她很紧张，所以她就走到后台说：“嘿，你很紧张吗？”我就说：“哦，不，不。”于是我走上了台，这绝对是真的，
I went out, she was being completely nice, but as I was answering questions going, yes, I'm from Colorado, a tear. No way. And I watched the interview, I'm smiling and I just gently wipe it away, and I'm from Colorado, I'm having a full panic. I go back to the hotel, which was, they flew you to New York and did the whole thing.
我走上了台，她对真的我超级友好，但当我一边回答问题一边说着“是的，我来自科罗拉多州”时，一滴眼泪（流了下来）。不会吧。我看着那段采访，我脸上带着微笑，然后轻轻地把它擦掉，嘴里说着“我来自科罗拉多州”，而我其实正在经历全面的恐慌。我回到酒店——他们把我飞机接到纽约然后进行了一整套流程，
And I locked myself in the bathroom and I was just mortified that I had done such a bad job and was so embarrassed and beating up on myself. And my awesome friend, Canadian friend, Will Arnett would love, we had gone out for drinks after, or like maybe the next day, and I remember Alana said,
我把自己锁在浴室里，对自己的糟糕表现感到万分难堪、极其尴尬，并且一直在狠狠地自责。而我超棒的朋友、加拿大朋友威尔·阿奈特（Will Arnett）——这是他会乐意听到的——我们之后去喝了酒，或者可能是第二天，我记得阿拉纳说过，
I said, oh my God, I did such a bad job on this thing, and you know, I was so bad, and she said, you know who I just saw on David Letterman? Kim Basinger was on David Letterman, and she was so nervous, and I remember I liked her so much because I thought I would be nervous on that thing too. It made me stop hating the nervousness about myself so much
我说：“天哪，我刚才表现得太糟糕了，你知道的，我太差劲了。”她说：“你知道我刚刚在大卫·莱特曼的节目上看到谁了吗？金·贝辛格上了大卫·莱特曼的节目，她当时也紧张得要命。”我记得我当时超级喜欢她，因为我想：原来我在那种场合也会紧张啊。这让我不再那么讨厌自己身上的紧张情绪了，
and I went, I'm nervous, what are you going to fucking do? And people who are like so, no offense to everyone who's so funny and good, but you know, because you guys are all so good at it. You guys are so good, but not everyone is so so good And the dirty little secret is that even even the the the flashy sort of funny sort of I I don't seem very nervous person is Petrified yeah underneath they just have this flashy coping skill right it is basically Acting they're just able to act twice right just have this flashy coping skill that is basically acting.
然后我想：我很紧张，你他妈能拿我怎么办？那些表现得超级——无意冒犯在座所有既幽默又优秀的各位，但你知道的，因为你们所有人都很擅长这个。你们都太棒了，但并不是每个人都那么优秀。而这里面公开的小秘密就是，即使是那些光鲜亮丽、幽默风趣、看起来好像——我看起来好像不太紧张的人，
They're just able to act twice. Right? Right. You don't even know what I'm thinking. Will, you are very easy though in front of people. You are very- He is, but he's so, he's a fucking mess inside. He is a mess.
内心其实也吓得要死，对，在光鲜的外表下，他们只是拥有一套光鲜亮丽的应对技巧，对吧？这基本上就是演戏，他们只是能把戏演两遍，对吧？——只是拥有一套光鲜亮丽的应对技巧，这基本上就是演戏。他们只是能把戏演两遍，对吧？对吧？你甚至都不知道我在想什么。威尔，你在人前表现得很松弛。你非常——他是很松弛，但他内心其实是一团糟。他简直一团糟。
He is a mess, obviously. You would admit it right now, just like I am a fucking disaster inside, and so is Sean. We're all fucking nut jobs. We're all crazy. You just figure out different ways to fake it. And then you get comfortable with that and it kind of becomes a part of your personality too.
他显然一团糟。你现在就会承认这一点，就像我内心是个彻头彻尾的灾难一样，肖恩也是。我们全都是疯子。我们都疯了。你只是找到了不同的伪装方式。然后你习惯了这种方式，它某种程度上也成了你个性的一部分。
Like, oh this little suit that I put on to kind of deal with it is also just kind of me too. Well, I'll get real with you. So my version, through a lot of kind of work and exploration over the last few months, this is totally honest, is I first went away to boarding school when I was 12. You did? I didn't know that.
就像：“哦，我为了应付这种情况而穿上的这件小外衣，其实某种程度上也就是我本人。”好吧，那我跟你掏心掏肺。所以我的版本——通过过去几个月的大量心理工作和探索，这绝对是实话——是我在12岁时第一次去寄宿学校。你去了？我不知道这件事。
Wait, where did you go? I went to All Boys, up in Canada, and I went to All Boys boarding school. I'm not going to give them the benefit of telling you. Okay, but like what area, sorry, where in? North of Toronto. Like up by Muskoka? Yeah, a little east of Muskoka.
等等，你去了哪儿？我去了全男生学校，在加拿大北部，我去了全男孩寄宿学校。我才不会让他们占便宜把校名告诉你呢。好吧，但大概哪个区，抱歉，具体在哪个地方？多伦多以北。就像穆斯科卡那边？嗯，穆斯科卡东边一点。
Okay, okay. North of Peterborough, Ontario. Okay. That's them to come pick you up again, right? Yeah, but south of Fenland Falls. All right. So you could just to narrow it down, eh? Like right near Stony Lake, but I'm not going to say where, eh?
好吧，好吧。安大略省彼得伯勒以北。好吧。那是让他们再去接你，对吧？嗯，不过在芬兰瀑布以南。好吧。所以你只是为了缩小范围，对吧？就在石湖附近，但我不会说具体在哪里，对吧？
So there you are. So there I am, age 12. And I think that one of the things... I didn't know that. Yeah, yeah. And one of the things about that is when you're that young, I can't imagine my sending... Can you imagine? No, I can't.
所以你就去了。所以我就在那儿，12岁。我觉得其中有一件事——我不知道这件事。对，对。其中有一点就是，当你那么年轻的时候，我无法想象我把——你能想象吗？不，我不能。
Or seven when they go? Seven? Well, my roommate, first year, when I was seventh grade and I was 12, my first roommate, he had just come from England and he had been at boarding school since he was seven. Wow. So he'd been there for five years. I mean, I know it's a way of life, but can you imagine sending your kid to a story, a continuing story? Yeah. way of life, but can you imagine sending your kids? It's a continuous story. And he was very, and by the way, he was a very sort of troubled kid and I felt badly for him. But my point was at that age, and I don't know if it's dissimilar from being out on
或者他们七岁就去？七岁？嗯，我的室友，第一年，当我上七年级也就是12岁的时候，我的第一个室友，他刚从英国来，从七岁起就一直在寄宿学校。哇。所以他在那儿呆了五年。我的意思是，我知道这是一种生活方式，但你能想象把你的孩子送到一个——这是一个连续的故事吗？嗯。一种生活方式，但你能想象把你的孩子送去？这是一个连贯的故事。而且他非常——顺便说一句，他是个有很多心理问题的孩子，我很同情他。但我的意思是，在那个年龄，我不知道这和那时候独自在外工作有什么区别，我学会了如何应对没有爸爸妈妈在身边的日子，如何应付生活，当然是在跟其他——基本上是跟我同龄的其他男孩相处的情况下。
your own and working at that time, I learned how to cope with not having my mom and dad around and how to manage, certainly in a situation with other, basically other boys my age. There's a lot going on. It's kind of very Lord of the Flies-y in a lot of ways. Not, it wasn't that bad, but you know what I mean. I do, yeah. And so I think that that skill or whatever that thing that I put up,
那里面事情很多。在很多方面有点像《蝇王》那种感觉。倒也不是，没那么糟糕，但你知道我的意思。我懂，对。所以我觉得那种技能或者无论我建立起的那种防御机制，
I carried over into my life. I think that's what it is. I do, I've sort of been spending a lot of time breaking that down this summer, which has been interesting. Well, whatever it is, I like it. I like it too. I like my way, I love it. I stayed vague enough that I didn't start crying.
我把它带到了我的人生中。我想就是这么回事。确实，今年夏天我花了很多时间去剖析这一点，这挺有意思的。不管怎样，我挺喜欢这种方式的。我也挺喜欢。我喜欢我的方式，我爱它。我一直保持得足够含糊，才没让自己哭出来。
So. That's after the show. So, Carrie, so you do all that, and you think you're gonna quit, and you think you're gonna do it, and then you go, because you have, not only do you carry over from, excuse the pun, from being a child actor to then having success in your 20s, but then you decide that you're gonna maybe shift gears or not do it anymore or whatever,
所以。那是节目之后的事了。所以，加里，你经历了这一切，你以为你要不干了，你以为你真的要这么做了，然后你去了——因为你不仅从——原谅我用这个双关语——从童星过渡到20多岁时获得成功，但接着你决定可能会转换跑道或者不再演戏了之类的，
or go to school or try something else, and then you end up having a third act, which you're in right now really successfully, which is you start doing a bunch of films and you have two really successful television shows. It's really unusual to be able to sort of carry that on in all these ways. And I would say that you two, I pointed to Jason and Kerry, you guys are very unique in that way,
或者去上学或者尝试别的事情，结果你迎来了演艺生涯的第三幕，也就是你现在非常成功的阶段，你开始拍一堆电影，还有两部极其成功的电视剧。能够以所有这些方式把演艺生涯延续下去，真的非常罕见。而且我要说的是，你们两个——我指的是杰森和加里，你们在这方面非常独特，
that you managed to carry that on. Yeah. Kind of remarkable, actually. What was the thing where you went like, OK, are very unique in that way, that you managed to carry that on. Yeah, kind of remarkable actually. What was the thing where you went like, okay, now I'm in gear, I wanna start doing more and kind of, was there a job, was there a particular thing that kind of fired you up? Well, The Americans was just, the writing was so, I have to say, even in the beginning, it was a slow burn.
你们成功地把演艺生涯延续了下来。对。实际上挺了不起的。当时是什么事情让你觉得：好吧，我现在进入状态了，我想开始做更多的事情，而且——有没有哪部戏，有没有什么特定的事情点燃了你的热情？嗯，《美国谍梦》这部剧，那个剧本太——我必须得说，即使在刚开始时，它也是一部慢热的剧。
It was, I really think the show became good about episode five in the first season. And then it started becoming this other thing, which was really this dark kind of unravel of a marriage. And I always thought the spy stuff was just a way to push and pull the marriage, like sleeping with other people. So when you went into it, then you were thinking you were going, hey, we're going over here,
它，我真的觉得这部剧到了第一季第五集左右才开始变得好看。然后它开始变成另一种东西，也就是那种对一段婚姻的黑暗剖析。我一直觉得谍战元素只是推动和拉扯这段婚姻的一种方式，就像和别人睡觉一样。所以当你接这部剧时，你以为你要去演——嘿，我们要往这边走，
and you ended up kind of going over here? Is that what... Yeah, I didn't know. I was like, first of all, why do you want me to play this tough Russian spy? What, don't you want like Rocky's wife, that lady with the short blonde hair? Bridgette Nelson. I was like, me? What the fuck?
结果你最后却走向了那边？是这样吗？——嗯，我当时不知道。我就想：首先，为什么你想让我演这个强硬的俄罗斯间谍？什么，难道你们不想要像洛基的妻子那样、留着金色短发的女人吗？布里吉特·尼尔森。我当时想：我？搞什么鬼？
I was like, oh, God. That's hysterical. But she's not available? Her name was, yeah, I'm like, me? What the fuck? I was like, oh God. That's hysterical. But she's not available? I was like, so bad. I'm getting drunk with my friends walking in the snow. Why do you want me? I don't want fucking this shit.
我就想：噢，天哪。太滑稽了。但她没空吗？她的名字叫——对，我就想：我？搞什么鬼？我就想：噢，天哪。太滑稽了。但她没空吗？我当时想：太糟了。我正跟朋友们喝着酒走在雪地里呢。你为什么想要我？我才不想要这破事呢。
I'm still hung up on that image of you and your friends drunkenly walking down Seventh Avenue. It was, you guys, it saved my life, it really did. So that was just lucky, total luck just getting to do that show and then meeting Matthew and all of that. That was just good writing, so fun to be a part of something that was well received. And then I took another long break. I feel like that's what keeps me in it is I go in and out. I take
我还对你和你的朋友们醉醺醺地走在第七大道上的那个画面念念不忘呢。那真的——伙计们，它拯救了我的生活，真的。所以那纯粹是走运，能拍那部剧纯属走运，然后遇到了马修等等。那只是因为剧本好，能参与一部广受好评的作品真的很有趣。然后我又休息了很长一段时间。我觉得正是这种张弛有度让我留在了这个行业。我总是进进出出。我抽空
little pockets where then I'm just home doing laundry and you know seeing my friends and after the Americans you do after the Americans and it's on the Americans that you met Matthew and the great Matthew Reese who we've had on the program who's just an absolute love that guy. Yeah, Matthew. I just I always just I just love seeing his. Yeah, love that kind. He is. I love Matthew. So cool. I just, I always just, I just love seeing his face. I love hanging out with him. I had a nice lunch with him about a year ago.
休息一段时间，然后就在家里洗洗衣服，你知道的，见见朋友。《美国谍梦》之后，你拍了《美国谍梦》——正是在拍《美国谍梦》时你遇到了马修，也就是伟大的马修·瑞斯，我们节目也邀请过他，那家伙简直是个彻头彻尾的甜心。对，马修。我只是——我总是——我就是喜欢看他的——对，喜欢那种类型。他就是。我太喜欢马修了。太酷了。我只是——我总是——我就是喜欢看他的脸。我喜欢和他一起闲逛。大约一年前我还跟他一起吃过一顿愉快的午餐呢。
Oh, you did? With Chris Tickeye. With our mutual friend Chris Tickeye. With Ray? Yes. Yeah. Who's equally as great. Oh my God.
哦，是吗？和克里斯·蒂凯一起。和我们的共同好友克里斯·蒂凯一起。和雷吗？对。对。他同样也很棒。噢天哪。
Who's equally as delightful. Oh my God. Delightful. Yeah. And that was a lot of fun. And so you meet Matthew and you guys are on the show together and then of course it makes sense. You guys make sense to me by the way.
同样讨人喜欢。噢天哪。讨人喜欢。对。那次非常有趣。所以你遇到了马修，你们一起演了那部剧，然后理所当然地，你们——你们俩在一起我觉得很般配。
Yeah, he's great. He is really, really great. You guys had never met before the show? We had met, which he reminded me about, which I don't know if he told you guys on the show, but he... I think I remember this. Yeah, we had gone to fight training or something in the first week. Well, we screen tested everything, blah, blah, blah,
对，他很棒。他真的、真的很棒。你们在拍这部剧之前从来没见过面吗？我们其实见过，他提醒了我这一点，我不知道他在节目里有没有跟你们提过，但他说……我想我记得这个。对，我们在第一周去进行了武术训练什么的。嗯，我们试镜了所有东西，巴拉巴拉的，
did the fight training. And so I'd known him just like that, you know? And then we were having lunch after doing some kind of crazy fight training. And he said, we've met before. And I said, no. Yeah, I remember this. We have. And he said, we were at that kickball party in Rustic Canyon.
进行了武术训练。所以我当时就那样认识了他，你知道吗？然后我们在进行某种疯狂的武术训练后一起吃午餐。他说：“我们以前见过。”我说：“没有。”对，我记得这个。我们见过。他说：“我们当时在鲁斯蒂峡谷的那场地掷球派对上。”
We were the last people at the barbecue or whatever and I was trying to get you to stay. And so I was trying to open a beer without a beer. He tried to do it with his thumb. And I knew exactly. I said, oh my God, of course, I remember, you left a drunk message on my machine, and I was moving to New York that day, and so it had been 10 years had passed. Wow, wow. And then, yeah, and then game was on.
我们是烧烤晚会或是别的什么活动最后离开的人，当时我一直在试图让你留下来。于是我想用大拇指不用开瓶器把一瓶啤酒打开。我立刻就明白了。我说：“噢天哪，当然，我想起来了，你在我的语音信箱里留了一条喝醉酒的留言，我那天正好要搬去纽约，所以这已经是10年前的事了。”哇，哇。然后，对，接着好戏开场了。
Isn't that so crazy? Well, so Sean, don't feel so bad that she didn't remember seeing you in the garden of the acting teacher. That's fine. She didn't remember meeting her husband. She didn't remember her husband, yeah, okay. I get it, I get it, I get it.
这难道不疯狂吗？好吧，所以肖恩，别觉得她不记得在表演老师的花园里见过你是什么丢脸的事了。没关系。她连自己跟丈夫初次见面都不记得了。她连丈夫都不记得了，好吧。我懂，我懂，我懂。
I get it, I have one of those faces. But I love a good love story, so to the extent you feel comfortable, what changed from the, you know, when you try to open the beer for you. You had the kickball party. And you didn't clap. Did you do a lot of other hipster stuff at parties,
我懂，我长了一张大众脸。不过我很喜欢美好的爱情故事，所以在你觉得舒适的范围内，是什么改变了——你知道的，从他试图为你开啤酒的时候开始。你们在那个地掷球派对上相遇。而你当时并没有给面子鼓掌。你在派对上有没有做过很多其他文青会做的事，
like playing kickball that are like ironic games? No, but like what changed for you 10 years later that didn't spark for you the first time? Who knows, Sean? Who knows, okay. Okay, I'm trying to think, I'm trying to think. No, you don't have to answer. Number one.
比如玩一些带有讽刺意味的游戏，像地掷球？没有，但是是什么让你在10年后发生了改变，而第一次却没有擦出火花？谁知道呢，肖恩？谁知道呢，好吧。好吧，我在想，我在想。不，你不用回答。第一点。
It's probably a haircut. Matthew had his haircut better the second time. Number one, you know, I don't ever want to go back to my 20s. I'm not saying, I don't ever want to go back to my 20s. I'm not saying, there are certain things about our bodies now as they're aging, but I like who I am so much more now.
那可能是一个发型。马修第二次时的发型弄得更好。第一点，你知道的，我永远不想回到我20多岁的时候。我不是说——我永远不想回到我20多岁的时候。我不是说，我们现在随着年龄增长的身体有些地方——但我现在更喜欢现在的自己了。
I look at my girlfriends, I think they are so beautiful now. I don't ever want to go back to 20s. I love our age now, and I think in our 30s, or when I met him again, which would have been in my mid 30s or about then, I just was a different person. You know what I mean? I was, and I wanted something different. I also think that, Carrie, and this is a compliment to you, Carrie, which is that like you probably don't remember because you're such an authentic person. And I don't think that,
我看着我的女性朋友们，觉得她们现在美极了。我永远不想回到20多岁。我太喜欢我们现在的年龄了，而且我觉得在我们30多岁时，或者当我再次遇到他时，那大概是我30岁中期或者差不多那个时候，我整个人已经变成了一个不同的人。你知道我的意思吗？我变了，我想要一些不同的东西。我甚至还觉得，加里——这也是在称赞你，加里——那就是你可能都不记得了，因为你是一个那么真实的人。我不认为——
I think you'd remember somebody if you actually had a real conversation you really connected in that way. Yeah, and not through a beer pub. Yeah, you're not distracted by shiny moving objects at all. No, no. You're really a real person. Go ahead, Sean.
我觉得只有当你真的进行了一次真正的对话、以那种方式真正建立连接时，你才会记住一个人。对，而不是通过一瓶啤酒。对，你根本不会被那些闪闪发光移动的物体所分心。不，不。你真的是个真实的人。说吧，肖恩。
No, I'm distracted by shiny objects. Anything with frosting on it. Yeah, I get're really a real person. Go ahead, Sean. No, I'm distracted by Shiny. I'm anything with frosting on it. Yes, I like it. Oh my God. Shiny and pretty things are nice too. Right, but Mission Impossible, Incredible, I'm a big popcorn movie guy. Sorry, did any of those-
不，我会被闪闪发光的东西分心。任何带糖霜的东西。对，我——你真的是个真实的人。说吧，肖恩。不，我会被闪闪发光的东西分心。任何带糖霜的东西。是的，我喜欢。噢天哪。闪亮漂亮的东西也很棒。对，不过《碟中谍》，不可思议，我绝对是个爆米花电影迷。抱歉，这里面有什么——
Awesome death. Did the Mission end up being possible because they didn't do it, right? So I think that's a little bit of a- Well, you never knew what the rabbit's foot was. You never knew what the rabbit's foot was. You never knew what the rabbit's foot was. No, but I kind of want to like, I want to be like, well, turned out it was possible.
帅气的死法。那部《碟中谍》最终真的“谍中谍”了吗，因为他们没去完成，对吧？所以我觉得这有点——好吧，你永远不会知道那只兔脚到底是什么。你永远不会知道那只兔脚到底是什么。你永远不会知道那只兔脚到底是什么。不，但我有点想——我想说：好吧，结果证明这是可能的。
It's kind of like never ending story. Did the movie end? It sure did. It sure did. Don't hold your arms. Yeah. So, I mean, class action lawsuit much? I mean...
这有点像《大魔域》。电影结束了吗？当然结束了。确实结束了。别死撑着。所以，我是说，这得算集体诉讼了吧？我是说……
But I loved that. And then when it was revealed that it was you in Star Wars, I mean, I was blown away. Like that was the coolest thing. Oh, fuck. Here we go. Sorry, Carrie. No, I love it.
但我好喜欢那个。后来当揭晓《星球大战》里那个带着头盔的人就是你时，我的天，我整个人惊呆了。那简直是最酷的事情。哦，操。又来了。抱歉，加里。不，我喜欢。
Go. I mean, I was watching it and even Scott and I were like, who is this? I recognize your voice, but I couldn't because we didn't see your face. I was like, did you ever reveal yourself? I don't think you did. Well, JJ never wanted me to reveal my face. I never wanted to reveal the face. And then at a certain point,
继续。我的意思是，我当时在看这部电影，甚至连斯科特和我都在想：这人是谁？我认得你的声音，但我认不出来，因为我们看不到你的脸。我就想：你后来有露过脸吗？我觉得你没有。嗯，J·J（艾布拉姆斯）从不希望我露出真容。我从来不想露出真容。然后到了某个特定阶段，
I think it was the studio or someone said, you have to show her face. And JJ was like, no, it's my whole idea. It's like, it was like that girl, there was some cartoon with a girl on a motorcycle from when he was a kid who always had a helmet on. And then he was like, well, what if we just show her eyes? And so that was
我想是制片厂还是什么人说：“你必须让她露脸。”J·J就说：“不，这是我的整体构思。”这就像——就像那个女孩，他小时候看过的一部动画片里有个骑摩托车的女孩，一直戴着头盔。然后他说：“好吧，如果我们只露出她的眼睛会怎么样？”所以那就是——
but I think they wanted me to take the helmet off but yeah you know it was like yeah we got Carrie Russell we're not gonna not reveal yeah yeah but was such a kick-ass amazing it was a bit short and just knowing Sean that she was from Endalore I mean that must have been for you right knowing that how many moons and it was away it was incredible from tattooing you must have been for you, right? Knowing how many moons it was away. It was incredible. From Tatooine, you must have been like just freaking out. I mean, as an adult, paying attention to a kid's story
但我猜他们还是想让我摘下头盔，不过，你知道的，当时的感觉就像是：耶，我们找来凯丽·拉塞尔了，我们可不能不让她露脸。耶，耶。但那个角色简直酷毙了、太惊艳了。只是有点短，而且一想到她来自安多尔，肖恩，这一定让你——对吧？一想到它距离塔图因有多少光年之遥，你肯定觉得——作为成年人，去关注一个儿童故事，
must have been so cool for you. I loved it, I loved it. And then I haven't seen Cocaine Bear and I really, really want to see it, but I heard it's great and it's been out for a while. It's so stupid and crazy and nuts and Margot Martindale is... I mean, you guys, what she does... She's the greatest.
对你来说一定太酷了。我超爱，我太爱了。然后我还没看过《可卡因熊》，但我真的很想看，我听说这部片子超棒，而且上映好一阵子了。它太蠢、太疯狂、太荒谬了，玛戈·马丁代尔——我是说，伙计们，她演得……她太棒了。
It's ridiculous and wild and it's such... It was just an antidote to COVID and everyone being stuck in their houses and it's... And the great Liz Banks. And our friend Liz Banks. We love Banks. Banks. You guys were in Ireland, I want to say? Yeah, she just called me, she was pitching me
这电影荒诞又野蛮，它简直……这简直是对新冠疫情以及每个人都被困在家里的一剂解药，而且……还有伟大的莉兹·班克斯。还有我们的朋友莉兹·班克斯。我们爱班克斯。班克斯。你们当时在爱尔兰拍戏，我没记错吧？对，她刚打电话给我，向我推销
this completely other, legit, serious, really good idea for this limited series, and we're just on with these writers and having these serious conversations, and then text me the next day and just says, hey, do you know, I'm talking about this crazy movie just says, hey, do you know? I'm talking about this crazy movie called Cocaine Bear. Do you want to read it? I was like, yeah, sure.
这个完全不同、正经、严肃、非常棒的迷你剧创意，我们当时正和这些编剧通电话，进行着这种严肃的对话，结果她第二天给我发短信说：“嘿，你知道吗，我在聊一部叫《可卡因熊》的疯狂电影。你想看剧本吗？”我说：“行啊，没问题。”
And I told my girlfriends, I have these few girlfriends in New York here, and I was up in the mountains with them, and I told them, I pitched them the idea for the story, and they said, if you don't do that movie, we're not going to be friends with you anymore. Wow. Ah, really, really. And they said, if you don't do that movie, we're not going to be friends with you anymore. Wow. Wow, really?
我把这事告诉了我的女性朋友们——我在纽约有几个这样的女性朋友，我当时和她们在山里度假，我把这个故事的创意讲给她们听，她们说：“如果你不接这部电影，我们就跟你绝交。”哇。啊，真的，真的。她们说：“如果你不接这部电影，我们就跟你绝交。”哇。哇，真的吗？
And it was so fun. Jesse Tyler Ferguson, Margot Martindale, and I traipsing around Ireland out of control. We were out of control, having the time of our lives. Why did you guys shoot in Ireland? I forget. Because the COVID numbers were down. Right.
拍这部戏太好玩了。杰西·泰勒·弗格森、玛戈·马丁代尔和我，我们在爱尔兰到处疯玩，完全失控了。我们简直玩疯了，度过了人生中最美妙的时光。你们为什么会在爱尔兰拍戏？我给忘了。因为那里的新冠病例数字比较低。对。
And because it's an island, I guess. And because it's a good match for that forest we were looking for. Margot's one of those people. She's so, um, years ago, she wanted, Krasinski was doing a movie and he wanted her for this before like the, the, the don't talk movies or whatever, or quiet, quiet place, quiet time, quiet place. No, I think it's look who's talking. I like don't talk.
而且因为那是个岛，我猜。还因为那里很符合我们想要找的那片森林的景致。玛戈就是那种人。她那么——嗯，多年前，她想要——卡拉辛斯基当时在拍一部电影，他想让她演一个角色，在那个“别出声”电影之前，或者叫《寂静之地》……寂静之地。不，我觉得那是《看谁在说话》。我喜欢“别出声”。
Look who's talking in the time out. Look who's talking in the, in place. Quiet time, quiet place. No, I think it's look who's talking. I don't talk. Look who's talking in the time out. Look who's talking to. In place. And he said, and so I said to Margo, I said, hey, John Krasinski wants to get in touch with you, is that okay? And so she talked to me, and then she called me, she goes, I'm gonna do this fucking guy,
《看谁在说话》在暂停时。看谁在说话在——在那个地方。寂静时间，寂静之地。不，我觉得是《看谁在说话》。我不说话。看谁在说话在暂停时。看谁在说话。在那个地方。他说，所以我对玛戈说：“嘿，约翰·卡拉辛斯基想联系你，可以吗？”于是她跟我聊了聊，然后她打电话给我，对我说：“我要接这个王八蛋的戏，
I'm gonna do his, before she, it better work out, because you better not have fucking put me on with this fucking guy. And it's going to be a pain. She literally like, kind of like pseudo threatened me. And like, I was like, I just put you in touch with him. It's not my fault. You didn't have to do it.
我要接他的——在此之前，最好一切顺利，因为你最好别把我介绍给这个混蛋。”而且这会很麻烦。她字里行间简直像是在——有点像是在变相威胁我。我就想：我只是把你介绍给他认识而已。这又不是我的错。你又不是非接不可。
I'm doing it because of you. When I read Cocaine Bear, that next day, she texted me, just as Margot, and she says, are you fucking doing this movie? I was like, are you fucking doing this movie? One of the hardest one of the hardest laughs I've ever had in my life was doing that series the Miller is with Margot And we did this episode. It was this thing where Beau Bridges was Doing this saying this thing and Margot and I started laughing and she got me laughing. I couldn't, it's the first time in my life I was like, I don't think I'm going to recover
我接这部戏完全是因为你。当我读到《可卡因熊》剧本的第二天，她给我发了短信，完全是以玛戈的语气说：“你他妈到底接不接这部电影？”我当时就想：你他妈到底接不接这部电影？我在拍那部剧——《米勒一家》时，笑得最惨、最难受的一次就是和玛戈一起。我们当时在拍一集。有场戏是博·布里奇斯在说某句台词，我和玛戈开始笑场，她把我带得笑个不停。我当时心想：这是我人生中头一次觉得，我可能缓不过劲来了
from this. I don't think we're going to get it. I don't think I can do this. I think it's a wrap. I have to go. And I couldn't look at her. She had me laughing so hard. I know.
。我觉得我们过不了这条了。我觉得我演不下去了。我觉得拍不下去了。我得走了。我根本不敢看她。她把我笑得快岔气了。我知道。
She's a delight. She's a delight. Kara, what are you excited about that's coming up other than the diplomat? What are you going to do the rest of the day? So I'm going to be honest, I stayed up too late last night, so I woke up in the morning, I had leftover Indian food, it was fucking delicious, I'm having a beer with it.
她太逗了。她太逗人了。加里，除了《外交官》，你接下来还有什么期待的项目吗？你今天剩下的时间打算干嘛？说实话，我昨晚熬夜太晚了，所以我今天早上醒来，吃了剩的印度菜，简直他妈的太好吃了，我还配着啤酒吃。
Oh, I love that. God, you're so cool. I'm going to, we made our first, it's kind of chilly here in New York this morning, right? So we made our first fire fire and it was just nice. And... You don't even have a fireplace. No, sorry.
哦，我太喜欢这样了。天哪，你太酷了。我打算——我们在纽约今天早上天气有点冷，对吧？所以我们生了第一个火炉——生了第一盆火，感觉太舒服了。而且……你甚至都没有壁炉。不，抱歉。
That's great. That's fun. What a fun day. So the rest of the day is going to be kind of cozy. My kids start school for the first day tomorrow, so I'm getting everyone. I'm going to make a nice dinner, family dinner, early dinner for everyone, early to bed. What are you going to make. What are you gonna make? I'm gonna make skirt steak and a bunch of vegetables
太棒了。真有意思。今天剩下的时间打算过得舒服惬意一点。我的孩子们明天开学第一天，所以我得把所有人都安顿好。我要做顿丰盛的晚餐，家庭晚餐，早早地为每个人做好晚餐，然后早点上床睡觉。你打算做什么？你打算做什么？我打算做裙排牛排和一堆蔬菜
and rice and... Yeah, I love that. By the way, I've never been to Brooklyn. I wanna go check it out. What? We could have you. We could have you. I might have to walk around there.
还有米饭，然后……对，我太喜欢这样了。顺便说一句，我从没去过布鲁克林。我想去看看。什么？我们可以招待你。我们可以招待你。我可能得去那儿转转。
Carrie, I'm coming to New York in a couple weeks, for real. Will, remember when I ran into you? Which time? On the streets. With your car? No, you were shooting something. Oh yeah, we were shooting in Brooklyn, and you were coming home and you were drunk.
加里，我几周后真的要去纽约了。威尔，还记得我上次撞见你是什么时候吗？哪一次？在大街上。开着你的车？不，你当时在拍什么东西。哦对，我们在布鲁克林拍戏，你当时正要回家，而且喝醉了。
And I was wandering home drunk with my eyes, I was like, Will, what's this? Oh boy. Dude, dude. I was shooting and there was a whole, like the crew were doing, and she- What were you shooting? One of those Ninja Turtle movies. She just blew right by the lockup, huh?
当时我喝得醉醺醺地在街上闲逛，心想，威尔，这是什么？天哪。老兄，老兄。我当时正在拍戏，剧组正在进行拍摄，然后她——你在拍什么？其中一部《忍者神龟》电影。她直接闯过了封锁线，是吧？
Yeah, and she came out. Now I know him. We were shooting right on the river overlooking the city and here comes Carrie, and of course nobody stops her, nobody in the crew stops her, because they're like, oh, it's Carrie Russell. And she just walks through, basically walks through our set. It's like, what's going on?
对，然后她就出来了。现在我认识他了。我们当时在俯瞰城市的河边拍戏，结果凯莉来了，当然没有人拦她，剧组里没人拦她，因为他们觉得，哦，那是凯莉·拉塞尔。她就那样走过来，基本上是直接穿过了我们的片场。当时就在想，这是怎么回事？
Hammered. Hammered, just walking through, basically walks through our set. It's like, what's going on? What's that? Like, hammered, just walking home. Walking home. I know. But I was going to say, I'm coming in a couple weeks. Let's have dinner and or lunch. You, me and Matthew. Can we do it?
喝醉了。喝醉了，就这样走过来，基本上直接穿过了我们的片场。当时就像是，怎么回事？那是什么？就像是喝醉了，在散步回家。散步回家。我懂。不过我想说，我几周后要过去。我们一起吃个晚饭或午饭吧。你、我和马修。能安排一下吗？
I would love it. I would love, love, love, love it. That's fucking done. Oh, God, Carrie. I wish we could just hang out forever. We will. I would love to see you. We have chance encounters from mutual people, satellite people, but I would love to see
我太乐意了。我太想太想太想了。就这么定了。天哪，凯莉。我真希望我们能永远在一起。会的。我很想见你。我们经常从共同的朋友、各路人马那里偶遇，但我真的很想见
you. Okay. Well, Carrie, you just brightened up our day. It's so great seeing you. It's always a delight. Always a delight. Let's all see each other. Let's do it.
你。好的。凯莉，你今天让我们的日子变得明亮了。很高兴见到你。总是这么开心。总是这么开心。我们大家一起见个面吧。行动起来吧。
Say hi to Matthew for us, please. Please say hi to Matthew and I'm going to reach out. I'm going to reach out to you in the next couple weeks. Please, please, please don't. Please do. I won't hesitate. I would love, love, love it. Okay.
代我们向马修问好，拜托了。请代我们向马修问好，我过几周会联系你。我会在接下来的几周联系你。求求你，千万别。一定要联系。我不会犹豫的。我真的非常非常想去。好的。
Bye guys. Thank you. Bye. Thanks, Carrie. Bye. Bye. Just a delight. Just a sunny delight.
再见，伙计们。谢谢。再见。谢谢你，凯莉。再见。再见。真是太让人开心了。就像一个阳光灿烂的开心果。
How cool is she? She's just a Sunday afternoon. She's just drinking a beer. Drinking a beer and eating some leftover Indian food because she's a little hungover. She seems like one of those people that everybody wants to be friends with. She's so fun. When we did Running Wild together, and she would be, we had so much fun.
她多酷啊？她就像一个周日的下午。她只是在喝着啤酒。喝着啤酒，吃点剩下的印度菜，因为她有点宿醉。她看起来就是那种人人都想和她做朋友的人。她太有趣了。我们一起拍《荒野求生》的时候，她总是……我们玩得太开心了。
She's the kind of person doing her off camera would be throwing shit at me. Like a super easy fun hang. Really, really fun, really prepared, really in it, really just disciplined and professional, but cool and hang. Really, really fun, really prepared, really in it, really just disciplined and professional, but cool and real. You could laugh with her and then you can tell her, she and I both, there were times where we were both
她是那种在镜头外会向我扔东西的人。相处起来超级轻松愉快。真的非常非常有趣，非常有准备，非常投入，非常自律和专业，但又很酷，很好相处。真的非常非常有趣，非常有准备，非常投入，非常自律和专业，但又很酷，很真实。你能和她一起开怀大笑，然后你也能告诉她，她和我都有过一段时间，我们俩都
going through stuff in our personal lives and she was such a good friend to me and we would talk about stuff and it really, just awesome. I love it. And by the way, she drives her entire career, like she makes the decisions. Speaking of. And by the way, she drives her entire career. Like she makes the decisions. Speaking of driving, by the way, I sent you guys a video when we were in New York
在个人生活中经历了一些事情，她对我真的非常好，我们会一起聊这些事情，真的，太棒了。我太喜欢了。顺便说一句，她完全掌控自己的职业生涯，所有的决定都是她自己做的。说到这个。顺便说一句，她完全掌控自己的职业生涯。就像她自己做决定一样。说到开车，顺便说一句，我们在纽约的时候我给你们发过一个视频
of an Uber driver. Do you remember that? Oh, I do remember this. Remember that? And he was really kind and he was from China. And his real, this is a true story. His real name is called BAIYI. And I got in the car and I asked him how you pronounce it
关于一个优步司机。你们还记得吗？哦，我确实记得。还记得吗？他非常友善，来自中国。他的真名——这是一个真实的故事。他的真名叫作BAIYI。我上了车，问他这个名字怎么读
and I sent it to you. Wait, wait, spell it again. BAIYI. Yeah, and how would you pronounce that? And how did he say that he pronounced it? Sean, Sean, I'm glad you brought this up. How did he say that he pronounced it? By-ee!
然后我发给你们了。等等，等等，再拼一次。BAIYI。对，那这个怎么读呢？他自己说怎么读的？肖恩，肖恩，我很高兴你提起这个。他是怎么说自己名字怎么读的？By-ee！
By-ee! There it was. By-ee. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
By-ee！就是这样。By-ee。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。太机智了。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。太机智了。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。太机智了。少。这个剧集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。